you've been trying to lose weight and
your body is not responding to programs
that worked in the past
our next guest says this can be quite
common and actually caused by a fatty
liver take a look
welcome dr nash it's always great to
have you on the show
so good to see you today we're talking
about fatty liver and you say that there
are
three ways that having a fatty liver can
prevent someone from losing weight from
losing stubborn fat
how is that absolutely and this is
something that a lot of people really
don't understand about fatty liver is
that if you're in some stage of fatty
liver
it makes it almost impossible for you to
burn body fat properly
even when you're on a diet and the first
reason that that's an issue
is because only the liver can convert
your body fat
into the energy that your body can burn
so if you want to burn more body fat
you've got to rely on that liver to
convert it and if it's fatty it's acting
like a clogged toilet it can't do it
even though you're aggressively going
after that extra weight
well then how does someone develop a
fatty liver throughout their life
back about 20 years ago or longer we
really only saw this problem
in the alcoholic population but these
days
40 percent of the entire country
including children
now have some stage of fatty liver and
that means it's coming from our food
supply
you know as we get busier and busier we
rely more on processed foods fast foods
and restaurants
these foods drive a very sick and
diseased
liver which in turn not only causes
long-term disease
but in the short term a stubborn weight
problem just strictly dieting and
exercise
is not going to be the solution is it
yeah no it's not so if we go back to
that clogged toilet example
if i have a clogged up toilet and i put
more stuff in the toilet it doesn't
necessarily drain the water any faster
the liver is the same way sometimes
people will see a change in their liver
with diet but that's because they
accidentally stumbled onto something
extra
the diet alone reducing calories alone
or exercise won't do it
so you have the five metabolic factors
run them down for us
yeah so total transformation the total
is the five metabolic factors that i'm
looking for
inside every person who's struggling
with a weight issue the first one
is that toxicity that's what we're
talking about right now today which is
the liver
the next one is being overfed but
undernourished you're getting enough
calories
but not enough nutrition to repair the
body the third one is to retrain the set
point that part of the brain that thinks
that your weight should be sitting
higher than it really should
the fourth one is acidity which is
better known as inflammation and how
inflammation can swell up the middle
area of the body
and then the last one is up to seven
different low or imbalanced hormones
that if they're not in the right
position
you're not burning body fat no matter
what you do dr nash what i love about
you is that you
always bring a great offer to the table
every week so
for this week what do you have for us
normally my evaluations are 97
and that's just because of the extent
that we go to find things out for you
but if you guys mentioned that you saw
me
on las vegas now with jc i've reserved
10 spots that instead of 97 it's a 90
discount it's less than 10 dollars
you're gonna get two webinars that
explain
these in this information in more detail
plus you get the virtual or online
evaluation with me
we're going to keep you safe because we
still want you to be healthy out there
so it'll be online
and the best way to get it is to go on
that website and to secure your spot
that way the appointments are sitting
there waiting for you